[Music]
dj seriously congratulations i've read
uh a ton of just so it's over the top
amazing reviews
for your new show and for you that's got
to feel good man i i can't believe it
these are the best reviews of my career
and for the first time in my life i've
been doing this for 13 years now and um
the first time people are actually
commenting on my acting and not my
appearance
it's it's usually i know it's usually uh
it's like i think the best review movie
i ever did was a hustle and flow and i
remember
thank you
yeah you're great in that thank you and
i remember
somebody called me i think it was human
bookmark dj qual shines
and then someone else
they're
they're like hugging me and stabbing me
at the same time so i'm so used to that
so when this happened i couldn't believe
it and what made me really happy is that
they're going after the lead of the show
now they're going what after the lead of
the show they called him the pillsbury
doughboy
well it's nice to see that you've got a
good perspective on this
he's just so happy oh as long as it's
not directed at me how do i care
you are look you are looking good and
you've been on the show sometimes when
you've been a little scraggly but you're
very you seem like you've been cleaned
up you're clean-shaven you're yeah i i
just experimented with beard growing
and uh my i can't really do it uh my
buddy affectionately refers to it as an
indie rock beard which means it comes in
here and like kind of scraggly here so i
read this thing online to boost your
testosterone i don't know if i can say
this on tv but if you don't masturbate
or have sex for six weeks
your body will produce enough
testosterone to give you a really full
beard
and so i was all ready to do it
i know and so i was all ready to do it
and so to not do it and so
uh i made it a day and a half and my
friends were like dude you gotta
masturbate i hate you because it makes
you really aggressive
i know you don't want to picture me
masturbating but that's that's what have
you asked me friends are like dude you
gotta know
the best friends we gotta talk we gotta
talk dj
sweat were you like a raging bull were
you running were you running around the
room were you like curly of the three
students
i'm telling you everything was getting
to me and i was like i've got to take
care of this before i commit a crime
i fully pictured that i was going to be
in handcuffs six weeks from then with a
full beard
that makes no sense to me first of all
that theory that if one were to abstain
from such activity
that a thicker beard would ensue well
because every time you do that you
release testosterone but you get a
testosterone buildup and it has to go
somewhere it goes to crime for me but it
has it's supposed to go to your hair
follicles i don't know what's on the
internet leave me alone okay thank you
three in the morning i wanted to keep
pushing you until you said it was on the
internet
and it was on like webmd no new england
journal of medicine no lance i like it
was on the internet